I saw this in a friend probably a decade
ago he went on a a fitness journey he
was already pretty introverted and and
shy then he had upcoming fitness
competition which Justified 800m bed
times and militant routines and the
rejection of all social invites the
competition came and went but the
routine didn't change and it took years
for him to reventure out into some sense
of normality and this is largely a
personal reflection for me as well the
Allure of perpetually working on
yourself is very very high because
Improvement is rewarding but if you're
not careful you can spend the rest of
your life focused on those three eyes at
the expense of the actual reason that
you did monk mode in the first place to
be able to show up in the world in a
better way